well last time we got through the worst
game in the franchise so we'll see if
they redeem themselves the nope not yet
thus begins the era of when they thought
Spiderman needed sidekicks that are
super villains for some reason because
that makes sense right
fiend or ho or whatever it has a plot
about spider-man stopping a plane to
infest all the world with symbiotes wait
a second what oh and someone is
kidnapping and mind-controlling
spider-man villains to make them evil
I'm pretty sure the majority of them
would have helped out with whatever evil
plan you had you didn't really have to
mind-control them to get them to do any
of this Oh whatever none of this makes
sense
oh my god Harry look it's your dad he's
okay he's still the Green Goblin Harry
don't you care Harry aren't you gonna
say anything to him hit Harry no oh okay
this is where they clearly didn't care
that much I would say this one almost
feels like a game for little kids no way
yeah yeah I would say it because it is
it's structured like a Lego game you
start with a hub area and go to
different locations two-player co-op
collectibles you don't care about
unlockables simplistic design for kids
to get through because they're dumb
the main difference being that Lego
games were fun you actually had on an
old level design this is just a tool for
parents to keep their kids distracted
for a few hours so they don't have to
listen them ask for
or been 10 action figures which they'll
play with and forget about after 10
minutes you just smash and hack at every
pathetic enemy you come across until you
get to a boss or in some segments when
they were lazy you just get a tiny
cutscene where random character just
says hey let's team up and then
Spiderman says oh okay the gimmick is
that you get to play through it with a
ton of villain characters as your co-op
buddy I remember playing it with my
cousin as a kid and being torn because I
wanted to play his venom but I didn't
want him to play a spider-man because I
was a petty little brat but I settled on
venom because he's always awesome almost
always the gameplay consisted of walk
into an area the doors will close fight
everything doors open move to next room
do the same thing 70 hours later you get
the end I know beat him ups were a
popular style of game at one point
history but this is a massive step down
from everything we know this character
can do here let's test the web swinging
physics
well I guess I'll be walking then
everything is designed to look like the
Sam Raimi versions of the characters so
I suppose it's the last piece of that
series of games wow this is the finale
to that whole series including
spider-man 2 huh
went out with a depressing whimper right
it's the last chronological thing to
ever exist with the Sam Raimi movies
I hate whatever this is so much this
game does have somewhat funny writing
but that's not the worst part
it gets worse than venom worse is a
relative word venom is only a rating
seven of ten honest
gay love terrible ways to die see that
meteor shower he was part of the music
comparison some selections from level 8
include wasps with laser guided computer
put a sock in it but it's bogged down by
the gameplay that feels like busywork
getting anything done is a chore
I guess the premise of Spider Man
teaming up with his villains
well the scenario is about as likely as
fantastic or getting an Oscar it's at
least unique and fun I'm a little
weirded out by the fact that I have more
positive things to say about this
cheaply made kids game in spider-man 3
it doesn't harm the material it's
attached to and it certainly isn't an
insulting game but it doesn't do
anything to set it apart from not just
spider-man games but video games in
general they didn't make any attempt to
be wild and new or improve on things
they did before or did they go above and
beyond I don't hate it but I will not
dignify it by asking if it is a
definitive spider-man experience I'll
ride a game with things actually
happening in it so it has a plot about
spider-man stopping a plan to infest all
of New York with symbiote really is
everyone that lazy with the riding venom
is cool and all but must he be the
center of attention always maybe it's
just because the movie came out the
previous year and he was popular at the
time but come on so something goes wrong
with the suit and it starts spawning
like crazy and venom takes over New York
every boss fight happens twice the
second time with that character being
controlled by an alien which led to some
really creative character designs
spider-man even has the suit so he may
be affected behaviorally by it which is
where the choice system comes in you do
what Angry punk-ass murder man black
suit would do bring it on I don't care
how many of you
drop the device at once mu night hello
or you choose what the character people
actually came here for would do come on
guys there's only one of me and there's
like I'm all for putting choices and
games there are some cases where it
isn't appropriate for any spider-man fan
wouldn't pick these renegade options
because at that point he isn't even
spider-man anymore he's just some
annoying jerk with tentacles and a bad
attitude the only choice I could kind of
get behind is choosing black cat over
Mary Jane but even that's really out of
character sorry Felicia but I'm only
into redheads
everything in this game is so
melodramatic be it from the soul
searching through a war zone with sad
piano music or spider-man narrating
sadly over the events of the past few
days and venom kills himself or you kill
him so long Brock and tons of people die
and Mark Millar dies and everyone dies
oh this one's no longer useful good day
maybe this is also part of the rainy
films think about it
spider-man is depressed and has a
horrible annoying whiny grating voice
where is MJ where's cage in a search
party now you're no help at ABC MJ looks
like kirsten dunst cap and they act as
if Green Goblin was a thing fairly
recently it's like this game is a big
apology for spider-man 3 by doing the
same thing even better I never realized
how close these two feel to each other
there are similar animations and they
even brought back this robot design they
only used in one scene in the last game
didn't want those man-hours to go to
waste out guys so this one doesn't have
any venom screen time either though he's
at the center of the entire plot and the
reason any of this happened but he's an
only three scenes all of which are boss
fights well at least he's not Topher
Grace anymore and he's genuinely creepy
every time you do see him you can keep
others from
I will take the gold from you for the
gameplay you can switch off between
black and red suit really quickly both
having totally different sets of
fighting moves though I don't like the
particle effects and sounds with his
attacks he looks kind of like a Street
Fighter character when it should be more
like a Mortal Kombat character you know
you can fight on walls now which is
something spider-man should do so it's
awesome and they have this neat thing
called a web strike this move makes it
so you can travel and break people's
noses at the same time it's an awesome
mechanic that combines web-swinging and
fighting into one it looks great too the
combat isn't anything too complex or
groundbreaking but it's very engaging it
makes you feel as agile and strong as
you should the animations for the moves
are extremely well done it's just the
right amount of over-the-top and again
spider-man feels stronger in this game
thank God he was so nerve tense
spider-man 3 in that game he could get
beaten up by anything capable of forming
a fist here let's test this out
okay never ever gonna do that again Oh
get to the ball they're trying to blow
up the going out I am the bomb squad the
swinging is fine in fact it's actually
pretty good we finally figured it out
you hold down X for a second to boost
forward and you hold it down even longer
to go straight up
finally I still miss the climbing
mechanic from ultimate bomb squad but
the animations are very fluid you can
move at the perfect speed it's great
it's especially fun for when you do the
black cat chase mission that's almost
like a staple of this series now
missions where you chase black cat
somewhere spider-man to did it and
people like that one so we should do it
too this time you get to punch her in
the face a bunch of times then she makes
out with spider-man's masked face
III don't get it what lesson about
relationships should I take away from
this if your girlfriend or wife is in
the hospital it's okay to meet some
woman in a tight leather outfit on a
rooftop where you beat her up for a
while and then she kisses you violently
through your full body latex catsuit or
am i misreading the situation well
technically it's a zentai what and this
is getting too weird for me I'm just
gonna go fight electro again hey they
made a stupid costume look kind of cool
at least so they earned points for that
actually I want to address that electro
is the best boss fight in the entire
game this chase sequence is epic in
every sense of the word the only one
that rivals it an interesting design is
the midair battle over the Empire State
Building whoops I mean the Trask
building
yeah you heard me the Trask building the
harmonics will only work on the right
kind of alloy American steel forged
before 1940 only one building has the
right make up the trash building
yeah no idea what the hell that's all
about maybe they couldn't get the rights
but Peter Dinklage owns this building
now I guess halfway through the game the
entire city becomes infected with
symbiotes and you spend most of your
time at a shield base in Tony Stark's
office surrounded by a fence made of
loud noise which I can walk through just
fine for some reason the symbiotes are
vulnerable to Shou
you guys know the suit can breathe
underwater right and they can swim they
could totally get around that in like
three ways look
a ton of random Marvel characters show
up for the fun - including Wolverine
Rhino Luke Cage and The Tragically
underrated Moon Knight you worry me
spider-man Wolverine also has a pretty
cool boss fight where he doesn't think
you're actually spider-man so he asks
you spider-man trivia questions oh man I
am so ready for this I have been
training my whole life for this yeah
kingpin has launched a massive operation
tonight what he made dinner plans he has
assembled a large well-equipped force to
hand out multiple operations
simultaneously well he must be ordering
takeout I warn you only once do not
behave this way again so once you
recruit these people they can help you
along with missions even though this is
a different development team I guess the
buddy idea from friend or foe was still
in their heads at this point and they
wanted to make it work somehow here it's
easy to forget you can even do it but
fun when you do get them to help you out
there aren't really any side missions
anymore it's all scripted stuff that's
required to beat the main story so
there's not really any pointless busy
work they give you something on occasion
like swing kick ten guys or blow up five
cars but those are really easy and you
would be forgiven to just forget about
them and only do the story stuff the fun
part is during the invasion section when
you can help civilians make it to the
safe zones and fight the Horde it's like
walking dead with spider-man ooh
collectibles I wonder how many of these
there
hah hah hah hah hah hah hah hah no no no
nope hun Venom down huh okay what well
he that was quick he wasn't making much
of an effort to hide or anything geez
New York looks better than ever and has
multiple stages so it goes from being
same old same old to this disgusting
wasteland with skin growing all over the
buildings it looks pretty good for this
era of games on top of looking fairly
realistic parts of the environment are
destructible making fight scenes look
awesome when Spidey gets slapped through
a mailbox and into the side of a car or
he uses a special move and accidentally
crushes a storefront you start the story
in a small neighborhood and work your
way across the city as the situation
escalates so it has a nice sense of
progression in the open world the black
suit is a blast to use in my earlier
playthroughs as a little kid I rarely
used it because I wanted to be the real
spider-man but as a young adult I
decided to give it a shot
and it makes everything so easy you just
Chuck cars at everyone and smash
people's heads in it gives me that
nostalgia for playing his venom and
ultimate spider-man it's so fun actually
that I ended up using it more than the
standard suit it's almost addictive and
now I know it's bad to use because of
how destructive it can be but just makes
just makes it so much easier
wait was that intentional that's
brilliant
I am so powerful using this creepy alien
that I end up turning into a scumbag and
knocking half the city down while
fighting it's like a drug that you start
abusing halfway through come on don't
treat me like I'm an addict saying I can
quit anytime I'd love to get this thing
off of me I just haven't figured out how
yet that's such an amazing little
gameplay detail the story translates to
a gameplay mechanic this is what I want
out of this stuff the suit feels for the
player how it should feel for spider-man
to use even if the influence of it
doesn't grab you much in the story
itself and you ignore all the choices it
works in the gameplay so the point of it
is not lost the ending has one of my
favourite boss fights ever and a death
scene for venom that's nothing short of
amazing if you pick the red option I
think the concept for everything is fun
and it's a unique take on the idea that
these game developers keep pushing for
but it's not perfect a symbiote invasion
just doesn't work for a whole mess of
reasons ready to hear me get all nerdy
I'm gonna go full on no stops this one's
going hard no brakes on this nerd train
ready okay technically the entire plot
of this game doesn't work because in
1993's venom lethal protector number 4
scientist stayed that venom suit was
only capable of producing a spawn about
six times one be encouraged and the rest
being the group spider-man calls the
five Venom's in that storyline so
whether this story is in the continuity
of the comics or not it's fair to expect
that the same rules apply and the suit
cannot create more than six total
symbiote predecessors unless of course
the suits all spawned around six more of
their own creating an exponential growth
pattern population of one symbiote
immediately producing six though this is
also highly unlikely because the suits
spawn on completely random occasions
with euros in between using Carnage's
offspring toxin and scorn as an example
we're both births several years apart
it's also unlikely that this is indeed
the single Venom symbiote infecting the
entire city because symbiotes can't grow
and spread on this level without gaining
mass in current USA and
one car takes control of an entire town
of people but in order to do so he must
consume an entire slaughterhouse full of
pigs and cows to give the symbiote more
mass venom wouldn't have the necessary
supply flesh to consume in order to grow
over all of New York unless he get eaten
an entire city's worth of cattle first
he's also out of character for venom and
Eddy to partake in such wanton
destruction being that the suit was
revealed to be sympathetic and helpful
to its host rather than parasitic and
harmful and the amazing spider-man super
special issue number one playing the
symbiotes
speaking of play the symbiote symbiotes
can indeed achieve kaiju status if they
consume several hundred other symbiotes
for mass which currents did in that
storyline to stop the symbiote invasion
and make himself powerful enough to kill
all of New York venom will not be able
to expand his suit to this quantity
unless he had first absorbed several
thousand other symbiotes this takes
place after the purge device tinkerer
created went off killing all the aliens
in New York where the rest of these
suits came from why venom is not
affected by the purge mechanism and how
Eddie Brock could exist inside that
thing are all unknowns seeing as how the
suit does drain life and we're after all
so in short using the lore provided none
of this can happen this story is
impossible if you do the homework you
have much to answer for
virginity secured got that [ __ ] on full
lockdown oh my god what is my life so
cool boss fights fun scenes and dialogue
but overall has a lackluster story and
the concept is a little tired
gameplay is awesome all across the board
and I think this game works better if
you pretend it's spider-man 3 instead
just switch him out in your head and
this is the perfect follow-up - -
doesn't do anything new or crazy but it
serves its purpose well I think this one
is worth a playthrough for both fans of
the character and people who are new to
the superhero genre of gaming it's
really good but it definitely isn't the
perfect spider-man game there are a lot
of tiny little nitpicks that can be made
and the tone is wrong for a character
that is light hearted the majority of
the time the gimmicks of the black suit
and these moral choices they just kind
of detract from the feeling of
simulating spider hood
you shouldn't have to choose which kind
of spider-man you want to be you should
just be the regular one and love every
minute of it
just get this guy right no more of that
overused costume that makes them a jerk
okay we got the alien costume right this
time so let's just leave it at that they
just can't seem to focus on perfecting
the one and only spider-man which is
where the next game makes the same
mistake but I'll get to that one next
time one does not get where I am in life
being nice one doesn't get to where you
are in life without eating a few hundred
doughnuts a week in the interest of
personal gain I can easily ignore your
childish jokes it's quite obvious to
everyone that you are indeed a master of
personal gain Oh a sling like yours is
quite an achievement
you